let's read
from a lighthouse 70 meters above sea
level
i'm going to stop and i'm immediately
going to draw something okay it says 70
meters above so that's an up down thing
okay
70 meters right and the lighthouse is at
the top of that thing okay
a ship 1.2 kilometers out to sea
is observed okay so
the ship
is the ship going to be up here or is it
going to be down here
why is it down here that's correct
good okay so so number one the
lighthouse is up
number two it's a ship
it's a ship so it's at sea level right
so
well okay i'm assuming it didn't say a
helicarrier all right so anyway
one point two kilometers out to sea
what's the angle of depression
from the lighthouse to the ship okay so
from the lighthouse
to the ship okay i might even just label
quickly ship and
just do it look my house okay
did you want to say something yeah
right from the get-go
why don't you maybe just hold on and not
interrupt everyone else
i always look at you anyway okay
hold off give me a few minutes okay
tell us mention a great point which is
that this is in kilometers right and
this is in meters and because they don't
match right
yeah i've got it i've got to convert
i've got to convert because i'm going to
be in trouble later on if i try and mix
different units okay so good i'm going
to pop that in my diagram right
now
i'm after an angle what angle am i after
arleigh your hand up like because we
know we know them too so that'd be
objective and
the bottom one would be opposite okay
pause for a second we're going to start
getting on to the labeling of which side
is which but we need to know where the
angle is
first
okay now it's going to be up in the
lighthouse right
here no above that why not why isn't it
here this looks to me like the angles
from the lighthouse to the ship what's
the problem where else would it be
next to the ship
do you reckon it should be here no no no
it should be on the right angle
should it be here why not
okay now
where is the end supposed to be the
answer is out of these three
alternatives no none of them none of
these is the angle of depression
for starters for starters right this guy
down here at least if i draw it
reasonably is going to be 90 degrees
every single time right so that's not a
question it's just 90.
this is this is a bad option because
that's not an angle of depression
looking down that's an angle of
elevation looking up right so it can't
be this one yeah now lastly
it's not this because look at where this
angle is can you see it's measured
from a vertical line right like a
vertical line from here okay but we said
angles of elevation or depression are
from well where are you normally looking
like where are your eyes normally facing
and the answer is
horizontally right toward the horizon
yeah
okay so there's a line which is missing
from our diagram which we need to
include and that's where
that's where the angle of depression is
okay
all right now i was a bit mean to you
in that even though that's the angular
there actually even though this is
accurate it's not helpful right why
isn't it what do we need to do to this
that's not helpful like that
okay yeah i need this angle
inside the triangle otherwise can't do
trig on it how are we going to get it
inside
yeah it's an alternate angle with the
shift fantastic okay so you can see
there's the z there isn't there right it
is a backwards z but it's still the
shape we're after so alternate angles
actually does put theta in there this is
interesting right do you notice
angles of depression and angles of
elevation
they actually are always equal
no matter what situation you've got
because they've always got these
parallel lines okay great now we're done
we've got it inside
sakatowa so which which ratio do we want
here
how can we tell so
how can we tell
this is the angle i want
the 70 meters is
the opposite right so it was um okay
and then this one down here is
adjacent
opposite adjacent that's ten that's ten
okay so now i can write my sentence
tan of i should always say oops
degrees
um
tan of the angle right that's going to
be equal to seventy over
twelve
hundred not one point two you'll get a
really different answer you put down a
little bit are we doing minus one all
right so i'm gonna get to that in a
second right that's my next line that's
my next line right
so i'll say now tan to the now the right
way to read it is tan inverse
even though it is a minus one don't yeah
don't confuse it so anyway there's my
fraction in there and then you graph
your calculator yeah in the calculator
yeah like you don't have to put the
closing bracket do you
um so i would i would always put the
closing brackets sometimes you can get
away with it but if you don't mean to
and then you do some stuff afterwards
your answer will be wrong like if i if i
do this don't leave the bracket then and
then i have to do some other stuff it'll
all be included and i don't want to do
that right so i think it's
always safest
yeah
yeah yeah let's let's get the answer um
no it's three points wait hold on hold
on stop for a second tell me what the
answer you've got on your calculator is
i'm curious so that's about 86.6615
okay
all right now let's just pause for a
second
what's what's going on
you've always got to do this and this is
why it's important this is why i didn't
want to stop you okay
this this number
looks sus to me
okay because ac what kind of size angle
is that
like that's
that's pretty big right it's close to 90
degrees okay now my diagram is not to
scale
but this diet this angle is smaller than
86 euros in fact it should be even
smaller so what's gone wrong and how can
we not do it next time
instead of doing like the opposite and
adjacent it did it the other way around
so he swapped it so you're saying so
it's it's
we wrote down this is this what you're
saying
we did this tan theta equals
1200 over 70. okay good good so this is
really it's great that we notice this
because what does this mean because this
86.66 right by the way that's actually a
useful angle for something else where is
this angle it's not just wrong
where is it
oh yeah here it is it's
86.66 up here because that's opposite
and adjacent for this angle right so i'm
really glad we got to notice that
sometimes you can get answer and you can
see something's wrong and that tells you
okay i should go back right
so
when you noticed it and you said no no
no that's wrong you fix up your working
and then the answer is three
and 20 minutes
and you got some extra stuff which
rounds off and you don't need to worry
about it there's your answer yeah okay
make sense
cool